okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about the laws of logic and conditional
statements so let's go over to here and
talk about you know what are conditional
statements and how can we use them so
first of all what a conditional
statement is it's an if then statement
so
if the hypothesis
then the conclusion so whatever comes
after the if that's your hypothesis
whatever comes after then that's your
conclusion and oftentimes what i'll do
is i'll underline those quantities so
that i know you know which is the
hypothesis and which is a conclusion so
that's called a conditional statement
and this is just an abbreviation with
this arrow that says if p
then q and the thing that we want to pay
attention to is the direction of the
arrow so the arrow is pointing to the
right and what that means is that p if
that happens then q will happen okay so
that's the conditional statement now the
converse statement is said in reverse
you'll notice that we switch the p and
the q if q then p and the thing about
the converse statement is it's not
necessarily true the conditional
statement might be a true statement but
the converse is not necessarily true you
have to check it sometimes it is
sometimes it's not
now the inverse you can see that you're
keeping the p and the q the hypothesis
and the conclusion in the same order but
this little symbol here represents is
the negation so if not p
then not q and again the inverse
is not necessarily true you have to just
check it and then the last one is the
contrapositive and that says if not q
then not p and what we did is we
switched the hypothesis and the
conclusion and we negated both of those
now the thing that you want to remember
is that the conditional statement
and the contrapositive they have the
same truth value means that they're
either both going to be true or they're
both going to be false so if we know
that this conditional statement's true
we automatically know that the
contrapositive is also true and it's the
same thing for the converse and the
inverse if this is true this will be
true if this is false you know that'll
be false so there are called equivalent
statements now as far as the law of
logic goes
we've got the law of detachment and the
law of syllogism you don't need to know
those names but you just need to know
how they work and that's that you know
if p happens then q will happen so if p
occurs we know that q is going to occur
the most common thing that sometimes
comes up in these problems they try to
trick you a little bit is they'll say
q happened does that mean that p
happened
not necessarily it remember it has to go
in the direction of the arrow p causes q
not the other way around right and then
the last one here is the law of
syllogism and what the law of syllogism
is again you don't have to know this
name but
it's basically that the transitive
property if p causes q
and q causes r
then if p happens through this chain of
events r will happen so that's called
the law of syllogism these are basically
the laws of logic again you just want to
pay attention to the direction of the
arrow you know what causes what not not
necessarily in reverse right so let's
see if we can look at a quick example
here if you study your math then you
will get a good grade let's just assume
that that's a true statement okay we'll
just accept that as being true so if
they said
okay john got a good grade
does that mean that he studied his math
not necessarily you can see that's
saying it in reverse that's the converse
and it's not necessarily true
say for example they said
if you don't study your math
then you won't get a good grade now
that's the
inverse we negated those but it's not
necessarily true
just because that conditional that
original statement is true and then the
last one the contrapositive
if john did not get a good grade then he
did not study his math
it might seem a little bit you know
confusing but ironically this is
actually a true statement so when you
switch the hypothesis and the
conclusions we switch those two
statements and you negate them you make
them the opposite that's a true
statement so
assuming that the original statement is
true
if you switch the hypothesis and
conclusion and negate them both that's
the contrapositive it will also be true
just like the conditional so let's get
into an example and we'll see how we can
apply this
so let's just consider that these three
statements below here are true if john
is voted mvp then he'll get a
scholarship so i just like to underline
whatever after the if so if john's voted
mvp
then he'll get a scholarship okay if
john studies engineering he will go to a
local college okay so if he studies
engineering
then he will go to a local college all
right and then the last one
it says that john is not given a
scholarship okay so these are all
considered to be true so what can we
conclude from that so which is
necessarily true
is it true that john did not go to
college
well
let's see we know that he wasn't given a
scholarship but that doesn't necessarily
mean that he didn't go to college
there's nothing that you know gives us
that impression
john was not voted mvp
well let's take a look at that one so
you can see that it says
john is not given a scholarship that's
the negation of this conclusion right
here so if he's not given a scholarship
then it means that he was not voted mvp
that's the contra positive so that's
actually going to be true so letter b is
the correct answer but let's just check
c d for the best answer john went to a
local college well
if they told us that john studied
engineering then we would know that he
went to a local college but otherwise we
really can't make the conclusion he
might have he might not have you know we
don't have a way of proving that and
then the last one john studied
engineering
well he might have but it says if he
studies engineering it doesn't
necessarily said that you know that he
was going to study engineering so the
best answer here is actually letter b
and again it comes back to understanding
the conditional and the contrapositive
for this example
when you switch those and you negate
them that gives you the contrapositive
and it's going to be the same truth
value as the conditional statement so i
hope this helps you understand how to
work with the conditional statements and
the laws of logic this is something you
want to understand for the act there's
not a lot of questions on there about
this maybe just one but again you just
want to have a good understanding of how
this works review this problem to
understand it a little bit better and
i'll see in the next lesson